[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm Rhett and I'm link this week at the
round table of dim lighting we're gonna
get a little spooky we're gonna get a
little hairy we're gonna we're gonna go
through puberty we're gonna relive
puberty a little bit perhaps via the
question does Teen Wolf the movie suck
now how this came about
just to give you just give you a little
brief background is as you know link has
not seen lots of movies from the 80s you
had to take a breath there because it's
like it's such a big thing it happens
whenever whenever we're in a group of
people and people start talking about
movies that everyone our age has seen
like name a ubiquitous movie from the
80s
et I've seen that one yeah ha but you've
seen it in win I think I saw that one as
a kid or you know what I might have been
too creeped out back to the future I did
not see it when it came out right and
when did when did you see it a couple of
years ago right so they're just top gun'
gunnies I've never seen Top Gun I saw
Goonies a couple of years ago right well
you started seeing these movies a couple
years ago for Dirty Dancing I never saw
because that's a that's a girl movie but
you started seeing these movies because
you've got kids but also because we're
in these conversations that people don't
believe it cuz name another one I just
want to prove the point Ghostbusters
Ghostbusters I did not see it but as a
kid I didn't see what it came out jaws
I've never seen jaw okay there we go see
this I've hidden the poster I know what
happens in Jaws it's not about knowing
what happens it's about a phenomenon and
a shark about I know what I've been on
the universal ride it's all it's I
understand and so and because it's not
like there's not anything particular
about Link's childhood like he wasn't
you know there's not some crazy story
about link being in a cave others
through all of the 80s I was busy man I
wish there was but I mean I I was you're
like a kid business man but I didn't
know any of this was happening I was
friend the whole time I mean from it was
like Ben Stiller in the Royal Tenenbaums
as a kid which I did see that movie but
of course not as a kid and so because of
this phenomenon of him not seeing
classic movies from the 80s we thought
that something we could do on the show
is talk about a movie well have him
watch a classic movie that he never saw
and then talk about it and why not start
with Teen Wolf because it was a 1985
special one year after we had been
friends huh and I watched it at the time
and then I watched it again recently so
we could have a more informed
conversation and then you watched it not
too long ago as well you're gonna have a
discussion about Teen Wolf if you want
to pause the podcast right now and go
watch the movie if you've never seen it
we encourage you to do that but we think
that you can benefit from this
conversation even if you don't know
anything about the movie even if all you
thought it was was the television show
we're not talking about the television
show we're just talking about the movie
that started it all though we did spend
some quality time with MTV Teen Wolf
himself Tyler Posey we did at they were
at a fundraiser event called Stand Up to
Cancer it's super nice good month or so
back he hosted a live stream which we
were featured in and thanks to all of
you who donated our very own Miss
Perfect Jill Wagner was a one-color our
very own was a series regular on Teen
Wolf
but Tyler so we are talking about the
MTV show right now because but that's
all we're gonna talk so he was a cool
guy he was very very nice there was like
some outdoor food truck party and we
hung out with him for a good half hour
just having some quality time he may
come on the show cuz we hit it off so we
invited him on good mythical morning
that may happen yes hopefully it will I
like him he was not he was not he didn't
seem to wolfish to me but I've never
seen the show but I could imagine that
he could turn into a wolf
Michael J Fox so yeah I've seen I've
seen the movie the 1985 movie and I've
got some thoughts I've got some
observations and I'll verbally
that's the rest to see if we can arrive
at does it suck I mean and I'm gonna say
by today's standards I mean is it worth
watching so if you haven't watched it
will help you come to a conclusion of if
and when you should but before that yeah
Halloween is right around the corner by
the way as of the time of recording this
I don't know what my kids are gonna be
well Amaka my family has quite a
tradition oh you guys a big in of
dressing up now we haven't done it there
was a there was a series of years before
lot got too old to be too cool to be a
part of a family costume where we did
some incredible things things I've
probably posted to my incredible
Instagram Rhett MC shout out to red MC
it's a really relatively active
Instagram compared to links but I I
can't hark you with that so the
highlights are we did Lord of the Rings
back in it's like last year of true
cultural relevance like The Hobbit was
still happening and your entire family
before Shepard was Gollum Jessie was
wasn't he was a baby at the time so he
like didn't have much hair he I'm not
gonna say you look like Gollum but no no
it was your he wasn't a baby I can't
remember his out here he wasn't a baby I
was out here but he had she put like a
bald cap rubber bog cap on him
Jessie was okay I'm sorry for
insinuating that as a baby he did look
like Gowen but uh who live Tyler played
what maybe like right when he was born
he did what's her name Liv Tyler played
our area I'm drawing a blank that's a
little Little Mermaid I was gay and lock
was Bilbo Baggins oh yes he has a photo
he was Bilbo yeah curly hair I can't
remember if it was anyway we did that
and then we did guardians of the galaxy
because I had that incredible group
costume yeah that we did that we did for
the show when I was a rocket and so
jesse was Gamora with the the green
makeup Locke was the star-lord and then
Shepard was
the Arwen Arwen that's it that's who
does she play and then Shepard was
Bradley Cooper's character rocket
what is he yeah which I also was rocket
on the show yeah but anyway but then
your kids get to assert important you
can't do this incredible thing so there
was one year work lock was like it's
just a weird like scream character and
then Jesse and I were back like I was
Robin she was Batman and then Shepherd
was the Joker but then all right I
distinctly have a memory of dressing up
like a werewolf but it was simply a mask
it was just a rubber mask as a young
your own breath I would do the just the
mask with with the rubber band
and then it would like the plastic suit
you know that you would get it like
roses or skycity wrong Walmart didn't
exist right and they were just right
there should be aisle just reams of
these things and now you've got it's
amazing how these Halloween Town stores
it's in LA this happened but I guess it
happens everywhere it's like these huge
empty lots of where there used to be
like a Toys R Us or something we'll just
get overrun for a month with Halloween
costumes
there's so much business in it it's
crazy well and then you've got Halloween
Town which Halloween Town Halloween is
open year-round I don't get it man it's
always Halloween in my heart I've never
been to bit I mean as an adult Kristy
and I you know we're just we just oh
yeah we don't do much trouble we don't
like to have fun in that way it's too
much trouble
yeah you know it's like trying to get
your costume together and everything and
then you didn't let me say that I
wouldn't do it if my wife was not the
kind of person who talked me into going
to but thing is you would think Oh
trick-or-treating with your kids and
it's kind of a letdown but if it were
like a cool party where I'm like a
masquerade party or something where then
there's like a what do you know about
masquerade parties or like a kasi bin to
a masquerade party and I'm just and you
didn't tell me no I'm just a massing on
Eyes Wide Shut Connors
I'm gonna share that kind of I haven't
seen is that an 80s movie were you
completely naked except for a mess
haven't seen that one with someone
sacrificed I don't know what you're
talking about
Kubrick man Top Gun - it's not an
eighties movie but I did hear that
Nicole Kidman and Tom Cruise actually
made love for the scene for the scene
yeah yeah I can neither confirm or deny
it no no they were married at the time
they were well why we gonna act like
we're making love when we can just make
love is that a question for me anyway I
would think about going through the
trouble to have like a couples costume
type thing if we were going to a
Halloween party for adults that was like
cool and fun and maybe you could win a
prize prizes
yeah prizes but we always just go with
our kids and kids are starting to get
old enough that they can go
trick-or-treating without us even in LA
County I think I'm gonna be my wife's
gonna be out of the country and I'm
gonna be ii care of my own kids and so
I've got to I've got to do the thing
that she normally does which is make
sure that their costume fits and hat
they have one they probably what we
probably would just there's a Halloween
there's always a lot of last-minute
scramble for you guys like yeah I would
say switch clothes boys you go a
shepherd Hugo is luck well I asked
Lincoln Lincoln
I do remember Lincoln said I'm gonna be
and I think I'm gonna get the name wrong
he said I'm gonna be Jacob Sartorius and
I'm like who is that and he said it's a
kid on musically that I can make my hair
look like yeah he's like a kid he lives
in the up in the hills I there's a you
know what do you know about this no like
Locke knows kids that go to school with
him so I knew about him because you okay
he's like a who's an influencer but then
it's like oh yeah he goes its own so
school that's weird
how do you say his last name Sagittarius
Sartorius
Jacob Sagittarius yeah
I'm like Lincoln you're just gonna kind
of look like yourself
I mean you that's an easy way to get the
only rule of Halloween costumes is they
should not require a verbal explanation
just take it from me and I would caveat
that with in the majority of
interactions like in 51 percent of the
interactions you you shouldn't have to
explain yourself but you won I mean I'm
quite a lot of explaining I'm trying to
be well 49 I think okay are you nine
percent explaining the only existing boy
that a lot of people don't understand
pop culture stuff and they still gonna
give out candy the only acceptable
explanation in my book is if you have to
say well you wait until the other guy
gets here and you'll understand what I
am you know I'm saying like when you
when you've done like there was one year
in which I was Albert Einstein and Jesse
was EMC squared the thought bubble and
she had a wand that she would touch to
my head as if it was a thought bubble
coming out of my head so I kind of
looked like Einstein but she just looked
like e equals MC squared with a wand and
so together she we were we were
Einstein's theory of relativity and it
was pretty epic did you want a prize no
just you know but just felt great about
ourselves with Instagram that that may
be reason enough to just start working
on Instagram giving out prizes no I
think that a lot of celebrities are
breaking out they're you know they're
they do it all just for the photo what
do you think about that concept though
Instagram giving out prizes like picture
of the day and people win like a
thousand guys that's what that's what I
need to get back why is that not prizes
we need more prizes especially on
Halloween
Instagram should award somebody the best
costume and again they'll be like well
how do we know that you're the one who
uploaded it it doesn't matter whoever it
gets who's ever account has the thing on
it first and it's obviously something a
picture they meant to take they want a
thousand dollars divvy it up however you
want to just give people money they got
plenty of it instagrams got plenty of
money yeah Facebook money they're backed
up by Facebook all right well let's get
into Teen Wolf man because I watched it
and that doesn't happen a lot so we will
I want to talk about it but first we
want to let you know
that you can grab this shirt which is a
little bit Halloween ish Halloweeny
because it's the mythical beasts shirt
show it to the peeps featuring 9 count
of nine different mythical blue one two
three four five six seven eight nine
just think all multiplication where you
can just count the edges and do it that
way the thing I love about this one is
the closer you get to the shirt the more
information you find out about each
mythical beast the details go go far and
the only way to get really close to it
is to buy it at mythical dot store thank
you for supporting entertainment we got
lots of lots of ways you can rep it and
I always enjoy hearing stories of
mythical beasts who meet in the wild
because one or both of them are wearing
merch like oh my barista saw my mythical
beast shirt and said hey be your
mythical best and we had a connection
and didn't get a discount on my latte
but hey yeah I feel connected societally
societally mythical dots still are okay
first of all spoiler alert I mean I
turned the movies from 1985 but if you
haven't seen it we are going to spoil
things right from the top here I'm about
to spoil it so go ahead and go watch it
if you want to here goes
Michael J Fox turns into a wolf y'all I
mean I hate to break it to you and that
is on the poster and he's teen-aged he's
supposedly 17 years old I don't know how
old Michael J Fox was when he actually
did I think he was 23 at the time in
fact none of the people playing
teenagers in Teen Wolf for teens which
is not a surprise that's typically how
this stuff is done in Hollywood cuz you
can't trust teen actors you know you
give them direction and then they're
they're shifty a lot of right of T yeah
and a lot of regulation yeah yeah
they're gonna be tutored I didn't watch
Teen Wolf as a kid I did what do you
remember about seeing it then because I
can certainly tell you what I remember
watching it a few weeks ago well so I
had the opportunity to watch it I don't
think I watched it in the theater but I
watched
in the 80s okay yeah probably VCR maybe
at the I don't so I saw it in the 80s
and and then I recently watched it again
with my kids and the reason that I
watched it is because I was like I
remember loving this movie right I
remember thinking it was so cool now you
also have to keep in mind that in a
given year you were less than 10 years
old in the 80s when you saw it certainly
how many movies was I seeing right I
mean I was probably going to three or
four movies in the movie theater a year
and then my dad maybe literally renting
the VCR from Coates family video and
then renting the movies he rented the
machine and the movies all together
mm-hmm and brought it home and we would
do that and once a month so doing that
math really quickly I probably saw 15
movies on the high end in a year but
once you got a VCR boy you were trucking
all that to say that you really remember
you you were you remember the stuff that
you saw and there's something so iconic
about me it's got a great name it's got
a not only does he turn into a wolf but
he plays basketball and when he's a wolf
playing basketball let me tell you right
now wolves are great at basketball
turns out say what you will about the
wolf pack of NC State University but in
this movie we as our alma mater will
only say positive that's right they are
absolutely incredible
so Hagen well specifically he can
effortlessly dunk effortlessly dog
I cannot effortlessly say the word
effortlessly and but he can effortlessly
dunk so all the things that would make a
ten-year-old dribble to his legs think a
movie is great it had so I wasn't always
thinking about any of the cheesiness
risque moments with a blonde chick ya
can get enough of those but let me just
say your T G cropped shots of
toplessness I will say oh say that man
so you don't yeah it's cropped
tastefully but when watching this movie
with my children
I heard things such as this movie starts
in a weird place
yeah it was a first comment that I heard
late they were late they felt like we
had started watching a movie at the
wrong place in the plot we'll get into
that a little bit the music is horrible
yeah the acting is horrible the makeup
is horrible
the basketball scenes are horrible and
what's a dick nose dad yeah I was like
you would rewatch it with your kids and
in spite of everything you just listed
off you were encouraging me to watch it
with my kids and I guess it was for this
moment even tell me because your kids
know what a dick nose is okay well what
first of all clarify why you're bringing
up digging they figure it out
well be talking about styles dials
teacher his best friend in the movie who
is just your absolute classic 80s friend
I gotta talk to you because this this
particular character super cool guys in
so many 80s movies not just this guy's a
doctor comic relief kind of yeah the
trays an 80s movies trope is your cool
[Music]
InStyle friend ninja shovel hey man I
want to get a keg of beer and he has a
shirt that he wears for not for not an
insignificant portion of the movie that
says what are you looking at dick nose
yes you seem to really really like that
I mean how can you not like that shirt I
mean like you win when it's the moment
somebody reads it you've won you know
I'm saying it's like if somebody has
dorita they know that it's directed to
them and it's like I can't say anything
to that I don't know this but I bet you
they made it for the movie yeah but then
they probably sold it at Myrtle Beach
and other places and prices Oh like
hotcakes
you can even buy of course you can buy
that sherry so on and I mean
incidentally once he becomes Teen Wolf
and he's all popular he Styles is also
creating merch and a marketing scheme
for the Teen Wolf you know I mean what's
her name Pamela Pamela
Mick's girlfriend Mick is like
the classic bully yep who evil bad guy
and even though he was obviously not a
teenager playing a teenager in the movie
he's supposed to be 19 or older than
that maybe because he did time City I
don't know if he picked up on that
detail but they they referenced the fact
that he was in prison at some point and
that's why he's still in high school and
he looks a little bit older but
controversially but Pam I was saying
Pamela was wearing a Teen Wolf t-shirt
which Styles created and was selling out
of his Teen Wolf mobile yeah well I'll
get into the more details about like
specifically good lots of questions
about Mick and like where he actually
goes to school
well III will say that my kids
immediately started to echo a lot of
what your kids were concerned about
which was what's wrong with this music I
mean there's like there's something
wrong very Oh like distracting musical
interludes and like overlays and very
very forward with the wid the 80s music
I was like someone got a hold of a scent
and it just wouldn't go away
it was incessant well I think there are
some things that that help to explain
why the movie has some of the
characteristics that it does so
interestingly this movie was made so
this movie came out in 1985 another
Michael J Fox that you may have heard of
Michael J Fox movie you may have heard
of came out in 1985 it's called back to
the future and you see yeah but I have
heard of it I have seen it since then
like I said and Back to the Future was
filmed after Teen Wolf but came out
before oh really yeah so Michael J Fox
was you know in demand already because
he was on his own family time family
ties the television show which
incidentally Teen Wolf to t oo the
sequel featured his family ties older
brother what's his name
Jason Bateman Jason Bateman it was it it
was his sister's no yeah Jason Bateman
wasn't all family ties Justine Bateman
was his sister sister
the real-life sister of what show is
Jason Bateman on Ozark silver spoon
silver spoons yeah I'll be damned but
they obviously tried to get Michael J
Fox to come back what a tangled web we
weave Teen Wolf - we go back to the 80s
yeah well I think I think you're the
only one who well of that particular
particular weave I was on family ties
but yeah it was just the female version
of him Yeah right so anyway they filmed
it before back in the future back to the
future then and they felt I did read
that his mama on family ties got
pregnant so they had to take a hiatus
and then that's why he all of a sudden
was in on Teen Wolf but I did not know
that then they shot Back to the Future
afterward and it came out like a month
and a half before Teen Wolf was released
correct yes and just some interesting
parallels between Back to the Future and
actually they shared filming locations
so there's a street in South Pasadena
that is the so the Howard family home
from the movie is located on the same
block as the 1955 George McFly house and
the 1955 Lorraine Baines houses from
Back to the Future and then not only
that but the Howard house is the exact
same house as Marty McFly's mom's house
really all in South Pasadena now if
you're wondering why okay there's a
bunch of things in this movie that seem
interestingly they came out at the same
time but Back to the Future is a perfect
movie okay it is a perfect movie it is
you know yeah I mean there's many people
who make all types of movie arguments
that will make them up one wall and down
the other that that it is the perfect
movie I'm not gonna make the argument
well and I love the movie I love the
t-shirts even more than the movie for a
long time well here's one of them here's
one of the big differences between the
two movies so the budget of Back to the
Future in 1985 was 19 million dollars
and how much did it make it made three
hundred and eighty nine point 1 million
at the box office
Wow and I'm sure it's made a
a lot more than that since then now what
do you think the budget of Teen Wolf was
1.1 million dollars you saw this as well
I looked on the wiki yeah 1.2 million
and it made 80 million in the box office
so tit for tat it actually did better
you know in terms of a return on
investment ROI but not I think you're
just talking about percentage the
percentage not at the original budget
percentage it was ballooned like 8000
percent or whatever that is eighty
thousand percent eight thousand percent
anyway all I'm saying is it made a bunch
of money but it was like a 20th or a
19th of the actual cost and that's why
it seems that way like there's a bunch
of people online of like pointed out
things so cheap that make it seem so
cheap it was filmed really really
quickly like there's a scene where he's
walking down the street in front of the
hardware store and booth his girlfriend
who's not his girlfriend
at first she's not which incidentally we
now know that booth means fart means
flatulence but that just happened be her
name in the show anything we now know
that from the Kevin all hearings Oh
who's asked what booth met and he said
flatulence oh and but so then there are
there's a scene where he's walking down
the street and you can clearly see the
dolly track in the reflection the kind
of stuff that would have been seen and
taken out or corrected they just did it
but there's a when he's on top of the
van he goes by the jacket
jack-in-the-box and then he goes by the
same jack-in-the-box yes again from a
different camera angle and it's and you
can see these things and I couldn't see
it in the 80s and no one could cared
about it that much I'm sure they were
like critics who cared about it at the
time but the average moviegoer didn't
care about it but my kids have just
grown up in this in this world where
movies have just gotten better and they
care about stuff like that and the
nature of the realism of the basketball
scenes and all that we can't enjoy
here's the thing though I mean okay low
budget maybe I can forgive that like
yeah the makeups not great in the first
weirdies wolfing out for the first time
and he's in front of the bathroom
and they're showing close-ups of him
starting to transform the makeup is just
painfully obvious
I mean it's just it's just cringy and
then they don't have time to you know to
fix errors in shooting and continuity
things like that you're talking about
but to me the pro the problem is the
story and in a lot of the direction is
just mindless and cheap man I mean it
it's was odd it's just so bad well I I
and I mean I I can give you a few
examples it the whole story is weird
like once he becomes the wolf okay so he
transforms in his in his bathroom what a
scene and what a moment the best moment
of the movie so I'm gonna say something
absolutely positive that blew my mind
because I had I hadn't seen the trailer
I've never seen any of this there's this
whole build-up of him transforming and
that was kind of like okay I can forgive
the visual effects and the makeup but
then he's like having a conversation
with his dad outside of the door and his
dad's like you let me in there son I'm
your father
I want to know what's going on in there
and he's like okay dad [ __ ] if you say
so I'm I'm I'm gonna let you in and he
goes over there and it's like a build up
build up build up and then he opens a
door and then it's the best reveal shot
the most shocking shot I've ever seen
and reacted to maybe in any movie is it
reveals his dad is also a werewolf and
the friend he is amazing look now you
mentioned the makeup and I busted out
laughing when that door open and I had
to rewind the movie because I had a
sustained belly laugh for like a minute
and a half okay and do you know that the
producer awesome one of the executive
producers of the movie was interviewed
for the 30th anniversary I think it was
and well maybe was the best reveal I've
ever seen in a movie specifically I'm
talking about this room yes so they
interviewed him
because apparently they rereleased the
movie and that wiki came along with like
a three-hour behind-the-scenes thing
with talking to all the people involved
the movie I'm sure I bet it's not as
good as this I'm sure Michael J was not
a baby was but the producer I don't
remember the guys name but it's
basically saying he was so nervous in
watching the film and they definitely
saw it as a comedy and he said he
remembered that one of the first/last
was it like a joke that was intended for
people to laugh but he said when the dad
opens the door and reveals himself the
theater up it was an uproarious laughter
and it is it's crazy because his makeup
is nuts
I mean we're looking at it right now
it's like it's like if you were to take
a weed like a like a leaf blower and
spray it directly at cousin its face and
you would hope that all the the that
hair would part and it would reveal a
face on them in the middle yeah it's
just it's it's unreal the glasses really
bring it all together and if you had
never seen anything about Teen Wolf and
you saw this picture you say and I said
what is this guy supposed to be wood
werewolf be one of the things that you
would it be in the top ten things on
your list it would definitely not be in
the top ten things on my list like an
amazingly friendly monkey a monkey
they look like monkeys like a like a
bonobo and look at Michael J Fox look at
look at his makeup it's plain another
freakin Apes man yeah it it's like
that's what they were inspired by it's
not a wolf it's not a wolf but let me
tell you cuz I just can't but I know
it's great I can't lavish enough praise
on go but I want to go back to I want to
look at that picture while I'm talking
for the for the rest of my life I can't
lavish enough praise on that reveal
scene and I know I set it up with a
negative and I was gonna say negative
crap but like I was visser
this this moment redeemed the entire
movie for me I I laughed so hard and
before we came in here I watched the
trailer from 1985 for the movie and it
has this scene in it
they did not it's in the trailer which
is a horribly wrong thing to do that's
why I made 80 mil man because I'm
you got it you got a you know so I'm
really sad that you saw the trailer
before they saw the movie it would have
spoiled the most definitive reveal scene
I've ever experienced and I as an adult
man in 2018 I experienced it fresh like
I'm so glad that I got to do that like
it there were so many opportunities for
this to be spoiled for me and somehow it
wasn't when it's not there's how amazing
it is visually it's the fact that his
dad's a werewolf as well I mean it's the
perfect reveal yeah and I was I my guard
was down I was like this movie sucks man
and my expectations were so low and then
they soared like the change in
experience in a movie is also something
I've never experienced going from like
this is I don't know if I can keep
watching this to this is my favorite
thing I've ever experienced on a screen
did it sustain itself for the rest of
the movie
I rode the wave and it I mean again the
crescendo was so high that even though
it was a downward even I'll say spiral
from there it I still never got back
down to the low point before that I was
like this is a is a cool movie did you
did you pick up on the fact that his dad
said during the movie quote when you
want it you're gonna have great power
and with great power goes a greater
responsibility which is what Uncle Ben
says to Peter Parker and the amazing
spider-man well there I I mean I just
think it's they lifted the line man so
from the comic no spider-man lifted the
line from Teen Wolf oh it's my theory
I'd like to think that it was in the
comic before that because the as poorly
as this movie's written I'd hate to say
that I'd hate to think that anything
came from it I mean it in the direction
is just odd like here's the thing that I
was getting at okay so that's the
transformation seen the amazing reveal
moment but then that's just to his dad
the first time anyone else knows that
he's a werewolf
the second time he transforms he's in
the middle of a basketball game he's in
a tussle you
there there there's there's scrumming
for the ball and all of a sudden you
can't see him anymore
can't see Scott and they're like and all
of a sudden you hear oh you hear some
like some rumblings of somebody turning
into a werewolf in that pile and then
boom he emerges and everybody's just in
a stupor they're just standing there and
and look I mean he's he's a wolf and his
full glory and then he looks around he
starts dribbling that basketball and
then he he makes a beeline and slam
dunks it and then okay a human being
just turned into a werewolf and slam
dunk a basketball and then what
the game continues and very quickly
he's the most popular person on the
planet yeah like there's no questioning
of how how the heck what the crap who
are you a werewolf
are you up are you uh are you a planet
of the a per but what's going on here is
it there nobody cares is it there's
something beautiful about that nobody
queers there was a time in which we
would watch a movie and a guy would turn
into a werewolf and we wouldn't stop and
ask the annoying question or make the
annoying observation oh that would never
happen
he's concierge it's a movie he's popular
and then he's constantly the wolf and
he's like wouldn't you he's going he's
good but didn't you love it
didn't you love that moment I mean I
thought it was stupid it was so it was a
beautifully stupid though I'm just
saying when I saw that and I remember as
he was dribbling around in the meeting
the music when she starts dribbling
around in the way the music I know that
turn it into a wolf is unrealistic but I
mean and what makes you to waive all do
our wolves is this part of werewolf
folklore oh yeah that's that's realistic
are they good at sports is there any
other evidence that werewolves are good
at sports or see the only one because
that's sort of the whole that's an
original thing but you know what I'm
saying right I mean it's you can't have
a movie now where you couldn't do it now
used to spin your disbelief so much
unless that was part of the bit and
maybe we'll come back and make an
argument that that's just part of it and
we're just gonna embrace it but I just
yeah it's fact you cannot get away with
those type of choices now you know even
with something outlandish you've got a
but people have to if they're normal
humans in normal society they got a
react in a way that it leases believe
well as it was happening I told my kids
I actually paused it and I was like guys
just so you understand cuz they were
like shaking their heads in disbelief
while he was dribbling around the court
first of all it was a lot like like when
The Fresh Prince of bel-air would play
basketball and it was obviously like
write a set it wasn't quite that bad but
the the ridiculous nature of how quickly
he would get to places and the way they
would put those shots together it's just
all so obvious but that's just
ham-fisted together it's cheap it's a
cheap move but I deposit I was like kids
you had need to understand when I saw
this when I was your age I thought it
was awesome there was no like this is
dumb in any way I could not I don't know
what it is but I don't have the ability
to look at this guy playing basketball
and then go and watch television and see
guys actually playing basketball and see
a real difference you know I'm saying no
here's what here's what it was it was a
you approached movies differently it
wasn't there wasn't this criteria of it
reflect wasn't a documentary man it
wasn't it didn't have to reflect any
level of reality it was still so special
I mean we weren't years from having to
rent the VCR to bring the tape home and
be able to watch it I mean in the
theater the movie theater was it was
just so magical that it wasn't you
didn't apply anything from the real
world to it we were just grateful to
have it you know just so happy that we
were just in our realize we're on pause
for a second it what you weren't
constantly being exposed to media and
you weren't judging it against each
other we had no idea there's a dolly in
that shot you didn't know what a
dollie well we had in critics I'm gonna
read you the New York Times official
review but just let me say people in
Buies Creek at the time we're not
reading the New York Times period but
also not reading the New York Times
reviews of movies we made our decisions
about movies based on the poster and the
title and who was in it and when we went
to see it he was gonna have to so be so
hard for us not to have a good time even
in college we would determine what
movies we saw based on the poster oh
yeah I totally remember walking that's
how you run a DVDs that that's why
posters existed in movie theaters cuz
you were there to watch a movie and you
would see the other movies I mean it was
the it was just like a trailer and
that's what you would decide and what
and then when you started renting movies
you would choose movies based on how
many sleeves were up there it's like oh
there's 12 of that one that must be good
you know I'm saying there's only one of
that must suck let me tell you something
interesting about basketball scenes
because I found this fascinating okay as
you might have guessed that was not
Michael J Fox playing basketball when he
turns into the wolf
one guy is that he can play basketball
another clue is that he doesn't look
anything like the other mine the other
wolf in this in the film who is played
by Michael J Fox it wasn't that bad they
only why they didn't show close-ups of
another guy's face and yeah they didn't
make that mr. I I was fine with that so
I'm not gonna crap on an interesting
story so Michael J Fox is only five foot
four and they needed somebody to
basically stand in for him to play
basketball and they only made one suit
they only made one of the wolf suits and
it was a hand stitch thing that you had
to get into hmm and so they had to go
they actually I had a guy lined up
apparently a very short man who was good
at basketball and he backed out at the
last minute and they had to go oh whoa
whoa you want me to be a wolf you know
uh who was a scout for the Dallas
Mavericks who was also involved in
Hollywood in some way and was involved
with a movie that they got and they
found this guy Jeff Goslar who was a
basketball player from Loyola I can
never say that Loyola look Loyola Loyola
Loyola Loyola Miriam
University and he was he was like a
college basketball player and he had
nothing never been in a movie they were
like hey you're short you're good at
basketball and you can fit in the suit
can you come and play basketball like a
Globetrotter for us and he was like sure
and he did it and that's like the only
thing he's ever done in entertainment he
did great man dribble between his legs
dunk the basketball yeah I'm super
impressed he was awesome there was some
weird direction at one point you know
once the wolf is so popular but by the
way he's like he montaging around campus
like being everybody's friend like break
dancing with a dude which incidentally
that was I specifically recall that
moment because this is the case with a
lot of 80s movies but super whitewashed
right um you were talking like everybody
at the school all of his friends all of
his teachers
everybody's white and then they and then
there's one black guy that shows up and
he break-dances with him okay just like
you're right that that was it's like
they made these decisions and no one was
oh whoa whoa
maybe we should think about
representation a little bit yeah we're
not thinking about representation in any
shape or form Stiles had specific
homophobic and racist jokes like overtly
right but I mean offensive like I had to
I had to pause and I had to say Wayne
likes pause and explain and just to make
absolutely sure to my kids like okay the
reason why you don't hear that term is
because everyone knows not to say that
term right so that particular F word is
in the movie yes I remember I remember
that but what was I getting at oh the
weird direction so he he's breakdance
and he's montage and his way through
life as the wolf nobody's blinking and I
he's the most popular guy now he's not
with the girl that you wanted to be with
he's with the most popular girl who's
like the dramatic actress with the blond
hair and he's he's decimating the
opponents of all the basketball squad
so much so that all of his teammates are
bored so it cuts to a shot of them
playing a basketball game at some point
and like the wolf's going around and
like taking on the whole team by himself
so all of his teammates one of his
teammates is on the court eating an
apple like I mean that's just a that's
just a wood that's a funny directive you
know I mean the director is literally
saying someone on the set is saying okay
wait you know I want I don't want you
guys you know you're not playing
basketball give him an apple and I'm on
the Fitz about that because that's
either
I think genius I think it was genius but
it's because I got Apple and again you
can't do that now you could do that in
like a I mean you gotta have a really
smooth ease got to be really dumb it's
got to be like I don't have to make
direct oral choices like that that's
like this is a really stupid joke and
it's like silly silly yeah again it just
doesn't fit in the tight this type of
movie doesn't exist where you can make
directorial choices like that that's
like and I think it did exist at the
time and I think it was it was very
clearly if the kids on the court eating
the Apple yeah well we should we should
we should shoot a basketball scene and
there should be an apple being eaten but
I'd like to I mean so I can really
except for the reveal scene I can really
start to poopoo this thing is like it's
just it just doesn't make enough sense
and it's just stupid but what if you
before you if you're and I plan on
redeeming it before you I want it to
like to explore something that might
redeem it okay because I want to read
for you word for word because it's not
very long the New York Times review from
August 23rd 1985 okay yeah
written by Vincent Canby fancy New York
Times film critic do it Teen Wolf which
opens today at lo state and other
theaters is a high school comedy about a
young man a sweet natured nonentity
nonentity who gained small-town
celebrity and power when he discovers
that he's a
werewolf for Scott Howard Michael J Fox
being a werewolf doesn't mean baying at
the moon and chewing on the necks of
former friends it means that when He
wills it he can turn into a werewolf
who's a star basketball player and much
in demand as a prom escort the uplifting
point of all this comes when Scott must
decide whether or not he's willing
simply to be his non-entity self and
thus forfeit the fame that comes with
this other hairier identity for a film
that so innocuous Teen Wolf is
aggressively boring it doesn't even know
how it doesn't even know much about high
school life since the members of the
basketball team that Scott's team must
play for the big championship attend his
high school is there such a thing as an
intramural all-state Championship which
is something I said it seems like Mik
goes to his school cuz he's at his
school he's at his prom people of money
on the other team during the state
champion oh and this uh I gotta
interject the what's happened I was
baffled by that and I was like yeah the
the evil guy from the other team because
I was so confused and then another just
aside directorial choice in that same
basketball game in the final one where
he chooses to not become the werewolf
but to be his Michael J Fox self and he
wins the game at the free-throw line
yeah but before than like a free throw
scene before he it all comes down to
that sweaty free throw so sweaty
the unbelievably sick his arch nemesis
is standing under the basket
oh I'm like yeah that's a that's a lane
violation the directors like give that
man an apple and I want him to stand
right there when he throws that orange
circular thing into the bed get another
bucket of sweat they literally this just
man doused maybe it was almost how can
wasn't it was almost an unpleasant
amount of sweat how can you put the kid
underneath the basket
that's because because not how it works
because isn't that better than it not
being under the basket like if you have
a choice like if basketball could work
that way if you could put the bad guy on
the other team underneath the basket
with basketball be more entertaining yes
yeah the director was like I want to
make the entertaining choice if we can
we eat food on the basketball court yes
we can because it's more entertaining
can we put the villain underneath the
basket yes we can can we sweat profusely
and not have people wipe it up yes we
can all because a kid turns into a wolf
and nobody cares
they love it let me read the last
paragraph the film is over me a keg of
beer yes we'll talk about that scene the
film is over acted by everybody except
mr. Fox who was seen to far better
advantage in Back to the Future the
special effects aren't super but the
movie isn't important enough to damage
the classic werewolf myth oh no silver
bullet is needed to dispatch this movie
it dies a natural death as one looks on
whoa that was a rough review well that
but here's the problem we all made 80
mil this guy apparently did not go
through puberty oh okay here we go
I think metaphor huh
I think we got I mean obviously I mean
you know he's a teenager he's he's
trying he's in the bathroom trying to
deal with himself and figure out who he
is and which what what happens with what
are you doing son I'm trying to deal
with myself bad leave me alone I'm
turning the music up he's getting hairy
he's getting hairy yeah nuff said I mean
his dad says you got to get
hold on it's son oh gosh that's that's a
quote I mean it's it's a time in your
life when everything is changing and
it's you're just you're you're
scrambling through the ravages of
hormones to just get a hold of yourself
why do you think emotionally does happen
in middle school though if it's a film
about puberty why is it a senior in high
school well he's you got it he's a late
bloomer do you want to get Michael J Fox
he's a late bloomer what can he do he
can play a high schooler yeah an eighth
grader if he'd looked a little younger I
had to fast-forward through the the
fully bloom scene where she gets she
takes her top off and says what what
what makes you wolf out you fast forward
it huh well I mean I had my whole family
there and I'm not much educational and
you never know what they're gonna show
in like a PG movie in the 80s I mean I
had it this could be a birds and the
bees less I had to watch a woman give
birth in biology class you know why
watched it later on YouTube it was
severely disappointing so you think it's
about puberty which which is a very I
mean I think that is the canasta
consensus it's about the changes that
you that you undergo as a teenager that
you feel like you can't control yeah and
it was the moral of the story but it's
also I mean I think he was onto that
which is are you good you know the
question was is he going to change who
he is in his core being just because
outwardly he's different and like date
someone based on questionable motives
questionable criteria or is he going to
be true to his true self that doesn't
change just because you get hairy and
get more talented at basketball I guess
yeah because I don't know how I go to
the prom is yourself versus going to the
prom as yourself that went through
puberty I don't understand that analogy
because you go through puberty and then
you're through puberty but he can't go
back he
okay that is weird yes well I think even
though I'm a little weird and I'm trying
to make this work okay all right but he
had the choice to go to the prom as
himself with boof or he did he went
alone as the Wolfman Hey look at me but
then he ends up with her the girl that
he should be with as himself but yeah he
could choose to go back it's it's kind
of it's kind of a mixed metaphor here
well it's because it's like okay if you
with great power it's not written well I
mean there was such an opportunity so I
will say that let me so if with great
power comes great responsibility if
that's a message that's a theme in the
movie but then the application of that
theme is and with that great power you
know you don't need to use that great
power you know I'm saying it's like he
had great power but when was he actually
supposed to use it you know his dad
comes in during the prom scene when he's
being picked on by the principal the
Vice Principal it's always it's always
the vice principal
for some reason they can't afford the
principal hey you gotta pay that guy
more to act and in his point two million
his dad comes in and was growls at the
guy and doesn't he pees his pants yeah
so maybe you should just use the power
of the wolf very sparingly I is that the
see because he'll I also think when he
was making out with booth at the party
like he like clawed her back and like I
don't know it's like maybe I'm maybe I'm
projecting too much of like what we've
now in a good way or sensitive to it's
like being controlling yourself and
respect other people especially someone
that you're making out with or
potentially you know it's like mm that
was a that was a weird moment when it
was like but I think that was their way
of trying to say we you gotta be your
changing but you've got to stay in
control of yourself man Road but this
that's a that's a very good message this
analogy would have worked if it was more
of the classic superhero plot which is
you find out that you have a superpower
you learn how to deal with that and then
you use the superpower for explicit good
right but he gets the superpower and
then decides not to use it to win a
basketball game you know I'm saying it's
just an anti-god hey maybe that makes it
great he didn't let his hairiness define
who he was but he still is a werewolf it
is who he is it's not no thing that he's
not it's part of who he is but it is not
all of who he is
it is an outward manifestation it's an
outward aspect of who he is that the
only reason that girl dated him and he
was popular was because of something
that wasn't ultimately the core of who
he was and was so was he going to go
through life just leaning on the things
that people liked about him and that
made him popular and got him laid no he
went back to who he actually was with
people who knew him and cared about him
for who he was and got Harry only when
it when he needed it when he needed beer
he demands the keg of beer from the the
liquor store give me okay okay well that
just is definitely one take on it if you
I mean you play basketball and I went
through puberty and I got a lot better
when I went through puberty and I'm glad
I'm glad I stayed
what if Triton was play you playing
Triton harness central gym and all of a
sudden you're in a scrum with a guy but
you're on the bench
of course you're like but you're
watching you're watching I don't want
you to be in the scrum I want you to
being but I was a [ __ ] what are you
talking about just in this analogy you
were resting whatever don't go sidetrack
well you made me think that of course
you run the pitch now I know I started
man it was very hairy too you were an
observer at this particular moment and
then a werewolf pops out I mean the
whole place would clear out yeah I don't
mean to go back to this we wouldn't care
that he scored it's like Oh Who
not be there to see him don't as soon as
you yeah by the time you got to the
basket
everyone would be gone I just be doing a
shoot around by himself well what is
that true though am I actually wrong
would everybody pull out their phones
and film it of course that would have I
mean it's like if you didn't seem that
woman who got hit with the golf ball man
and her eye exploded mm-hmm everybody
just started filming it instead of
helping her I think first of all they
were turning to a well I think first of
all they wouldn't say he turned into a
where we'll have it look at that guy
turn into a monkey look at that guy that
looks more like a monkey now an
orangutan yeah look it's very long yeah
it looks like he's in bad monkey makeup
how did he where when where did he come
from man he's good I could see I did
that legal if it were a football I could
see that happening and you're like they
have like trick plays in football you
know you don't have trick plays like
that in basketball if I sit on a high
school level you could though if
somebody's gonna dress up in a suit it's
like the mascot suddenly getting in the
game and I don't know is this cool can
we do this of course the one thing I
didn't I didn't mention it's actually
just like the mascot getting in the game
tying into puberty you know who the
mascot was speaking of purely the
Beavers mascot was the Beavers so I'll
leave it to beaver Feldman's over there
feeding me lines to beaver you say that
[Laughter]
so where are we landing on this I mean
well the question was first of all I
have established does it suck for me
I've I've seen Teen Wolf I can talk
about it I don't have to like bow my
head or like no longer make eye contact
when it comes up in conversation wear it
with other cool people who like lived
lives in the eighties I did a whole
podcast on it did a whole pod on it you
should listen it's called it air
business I mean the reveal scene
highlight of my life highlight of my
cinematic life you want to get that guy
tattooed on your back
carry back I have a tattoo hairy back oh
man if you got that I would give you
item on my butt cheeks if you get that
if you get that tattooed somewhere on
your body that's awesome I will get
something that you suggest has it on my
body yeah that's the dad from Teen Wolf
I mean it's it's so good
that would look luscious on one butt
cheek maybe one PEC one PEC yeah that's
my take away is but does it suck that's
that was a question by today's Sanders
of course but is that even fair like
everything we've been doing though as
I've taught I've started to feel dirty
like with our modern-day assessment but
that's not fair that's why I talked
about back to the future yeah that's
true a contemporary film with it yeah
that was the perfect movie you're right
that was incredible
they hacked their way through the script
that to me I'll even forgive the
directing the scrip is hacky and that's
that's my that's the death knell it's
not anything else it's not I mean
everything else could be endearing but
it's like we're trying to make sense of
it there's so many pieces and they could
have brought it together better I mean
it's like we're we're forcing it
together to like have some redeeming
quality and like I feel like I put
together a good life lesson from it but
I did a lot of heavy lifting so you say
in spite of this script it sucks Teen
Wolf sucks that's it yeah is that where
you're landing yes I'm saying that Teen
Wolf sucks as well but you know what it
doesn't matter that it sucks you should
still watch it and it's still great in
its own way but it doesn't suck yeah it
sucks you knew that you knew that before
we started this what do we even do this
[Laughter]
yeah you should watch it though anyway
you should have already watched it and
this would have been a lot much better
but go watch it now and then listen
again
all right there it is give us another
listen um yeah if there's any other
movie a ubiquitous movie from the 80s
hashtag ear biscuits me I'll let you
know if I've seen it maybe we should do
this again let's say we need to do I
think we need to do Top Gun personally I
really think Top Gun they're making a
new one yeah because they're making a
new one I haven't even seen snippets
it's gonna be so fresh to me
yeah there's a great reveal scene you
can get it tattooed on your other pic
you're gonna you're gonna be fully
tatted by the time we stop talking about
movies okay
all right it's got a it's got what's his
name in it goose yeah what's van um I
want to call him van what's his name but
I don't know why I'm saying that val
kilmer yeah he's got Batman in it got
Val Kilmer in it all right but any other
movies like that let me know and let us
know what you thought about Teen Wolf
hash tag your biscuits boy this is fun I
learned something that fun I'm so hit
happy Halloween
[Music]